When an object is rendered into an image, at each pixel, the distance from the
object to the camera is used to compute its z depth, a value from 0 to 1. So,
here for example, I've rendered a sphere. And at this pixel, I found that the
depth of the sphere in 0.6. This value is then checked against the current value
stored in the z buffer. Which you'll recall, we've initialized to all ones. If
the object's distance is lower than the z depth value stored, the object is
closer to the camera. And so the color of the object is then stored in the
image's color buffer. So, in this case, the sphere's depth is clearly closer
than the maximum value can store in the z depth. So it's visible at this point.
let's say we draw a cube. The cube's depth at this pixel is 0.3, which is closer
than the 0.6 that we have storage for what the sphere did. So, since its closer,
we use the cube's color at this pixel and replace this value, 0.3 replaces 0.6.
Say, the last object we draw is this ground plane. At the pixel, it turns out
the ground plane's depth is 0.8. This is higher than the current z depth 0.3.
So, the ground plane fails, which is as it should be because the ground plane is
obviously farther away than these two objects. The final conclusion of this
process is that the current z depth stays at 0.3 and the color that's stored at
the pixel, this blue cube, is indeed the color that gets displayed on the
screen. By storing a depth at each pixel, the GPU can mindlessly keep track of
what object is closest at any given moment. What's interesting to realize is
that decades ago, when this idea first came up, of the z buffer, it was
considered absurdly expensive because you had to add a big chunk of memory of z
depth buffer that was just an outrageous amount. You'd have to add a whole mega
byte of memory which would be outrageously expensive. So, this algorithm
originally was a terrible idea. And memory costs came down just a tad and now
it's the predominant way of rasterizing triangles.